(upbeat music)
(audience applauding and cheering)
- [Kelly] Look how perfectly
bright you both are!
- We coordinated!
- We did.
- Psychically, we knew.
- I know.
- I was bringin' my Nirvana
grunge moment apparently--
or something.
- No!
- Yeah.
- I love this!
- It's like a colorful party!
Have y'all met before?
- No.
- This is a fever dream for me.
(Kelly laughing)
I'm flanked by Jessica Jessica Alba guys
and Kelly Clark, what is this?
- I like how you say Jessica!
- Jessica Alba.
- Jessica.
- My 12 year-old self is--
freakin' out.
- Okay, okay.
- That's okay.
(audience laughing)
- I promise you we're--
- My 12 year-old self.
- Not that cool.
- Is really cool.
(laughing together)
- If you're cool, believe it, okay!
I'm a cool girl!
- Yeah, so wait a minute.
- You too, you know, she's cool.
(laughing together)
She's cool and I'm cool, okay.
- Oh my God, I love you so much, wait.
So you're from New Zealand.
- I'm from New Zealand.
- So how old were you when
you started in comedy there?
- I was 15.
- [Kelly] Oh, it's like
you were young, right?
- Yeah, were all very,
quite young when we,
we're all very much the same,
ah, in the same, you know, area.
I was 15 when I started standup comedy.
- That's young!
- That is young.
- And bold.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, no one asked me to do it.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I know, but we're you--
terrified?
- Yeah!
- I feel like at 15, I don't know,
there's a lot happening.
- You know what,
I was honestly more confident
than I am as an adult.
I feel like--
- Oh!
- I feel like when you're a teenager
you have such like passion
and enthusiasm for stuff.
Like I was--
- Yeah.
- Just like a nerd.
I had braces.
I had like, I wore sweater
vests and had big curly hair
and I got the braces off.
That's the only thing that has changed.
(laughing together)
- I love your hair.
- Thank you very much!
- Yes!
- Can you see past it?
I'm so sorry, she's--
- [Kelly] I don't wanna don't see past it.
It's amazing.
- Yeah it's great!
- I always wanted curly hair
'cause my hair is like
(blows raspberry) same flat.
- Oh, it's where I hide all my secrets.
- Yeah, yeah, hide things in there.
Have you been in New Zealand before?
- I have.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- When was that?
It's beautiful!
- I did a TV show in Australia--
when I was 14 and 15.
- Yeah.
- So I went through New Zealand--
every time.
- Really!
- I flew back and forth.
- Cute!
- And everyone thought I was Māori.
- Yeah, yeah!
Well, yeah, no, I'm Samoan.
So like, you know, but
nobody knows what that is.
I just have to say The Rock.
And then--
- Right.
- And then they're like--
"Oh yeah, I know him!"
- I know what Samoan is.
- So wait, you live in London now, right?
- [Rose] I do, I do.
And did you just get your first apartment?
- I moved in, I'm alone.
It's a bachelorette pad in--
swinging London.
- But is it exciting?
- It is exciting.
I sing to myself a lot.
- Me too.
- Which is so great until I realized
that everyone can hear
me in the building--
like 'cause I can hear.
- Oh.
- Everything above me
and below--
- Oh.
- I'm doing two shows a night.
It's been tense.
(laughing together)
But it's, it's yeah, it's very fun.
I do miss it though.
'Cause I, so that clip
is with my real life
best friend, Emma.
- I love that!
- Who I love that cast in the show.
- Yeah, because I just can do what I like.
(laughing together)
and I wanted to hang
out with my best friend.
And we used to live with each other--
and we've moved apart.
- Yeah.
We broke up.
- Which is really sad.
And the thing I miss the most
is it's so hard being hungover alone.
(laughing together)
You know what I mean?
Like you want, you want a flatmate.
- You need somebody to order
a burger and a Coke with you.
- Yeah, you need someone
to watch like terrible television with.
That is the thing I miss the most
about living with someone else.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Now I just have to
call her and be hungover,
over the phone--
and it's not fun.
- It's not the same.
- Yeah.
- It's not as cool over Zoom.
- Yeah, exactly.
(laughing together)
Yeah, yeah, no one wants to
accept that Zoom request.
I don't know.
(laughing together)
- Tell us about your show.
It looks hysterical.
- Well the good thing
is I'm not a great actor
so I'm very much like I am in the show.
(laughing together)
And so I play a character
in the show called Jessie.
She's in her late twenties.
She's a New Zealander living in London.
What a transformative role.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(laughing together)
- And basically in the first series
on NZ, she has I'd say
an interesting encounter,
a wonderful evening with a gentleman.
- Yes.
- That's the daytime.
- Way of saying it.
(laughing together)
- An encounter, she had relations.
- A brief encounter with a guy
who turns out to be a
very famous movie star.
A kind of romcom will
they, won't, they ensues
in the first series.
And in the second series--
- I love this.
- Which is out.
- Yeah, it's very much,
it's a full-on romcom.
- [Kelly] Love!
- Which you know, I love and--
- Me too.
- The second series kind
of kicks off the moment
after the very ending of
the first series where she's
on a bus and she's figuring out whether
or not to stay in London
or go back to New Zealand.
- I like it!
- Makes a very impulsive decision.
And then the next series
is a six-episode long anxiety attack.
(laughing together)
So you gotta watch it, yeah.
- And it's no where.
- And it's full of regrets.
- Near real life.
- Full of regrets, yeah.
- Totally, yeah.
- So wait, so you were about
to shoot the first show
when the pandemic hit, right?
- [Rose] Yes.
- [Kelly] That stinks.
- Yeah, and I went back
home to New Zealand,
for like five months,
because everything got--
shut down.
- Wow.
- I went back.
- I went back, I was like, cool,
well I'm gonna have to retrain
to be a farmer now.
So the world's over and
(Kelly laughing)
I truthfully didn't think
it would ever happen.
I really kind of mourned the show.
Like I was like, oh--
- I was gonna say, did you think, yeah,
it wasn't gonna happen
because of the timing?
- Completely, yeah.
And we came back and we
made it really safely
in October of 2020.
And yeah, I was shocked.
It was a very strange--
- Yeah.
- Experience though,
because there were scenes
in like clubs and stuff
and it was the heart of lockdown
and it was like a fake club--
- That was hard.
- All the ESAs and like extras
were really stoked secretly to be there.
Like they were like, yeah, we're clubbing.
This is hot!
But yeah--
- We're around humans!
- They got to like it.
- Exactly.
(Kelly laughing)
It was very intoxicating.
- I love that, I love that.
Well, we have to do some commercials,
but you can see Rose's
show, Starstruck, streaming
on HBO Max.